three years ago uh and you'll you'll see
it right here from the uh much bigger we
had that earthquake has it has it been
three years three years 2019 we had that
force shock at 6.4 right remember and
then the next day this happened this was
taken in our eight news now newsroom uh
with a 7.1 earthquake near ridgecrest
you guys remember this i was in my car i
do i had the car turned off and i was
talking to my best friend on bluetooth
and i go why is my car moving oh another
earthquake ryan was in the newsroom i
was in the newsroom i was right there i
may have
either right there or took that video
and uh i was sitting down to a chipotle
i had not taken a bite and it started so
i immediately started a facebook live
and then the three of us were on air for
like the next five hours and then i went
back and i go oh there's that burrito
is it safety yes
i avoided it it had been sitting there a
lot okay earthquakes don't mess with the
chipotle so it's all right
luckily we haven't had anything nothing
like that right no not gonna literally
all right
let me show you a live look outside
right now
tara cam uh skies have cleared all right
we still have that haze from the smoke
the fireworks smoke that
smoke advisory talked about over and
done with wind helped clear that out and
we continue to see some of those breezes
outside right now that's a red rock
station casino tower camp i like this
shot during monsoon season because you
can see the clouds build up off towards
the east not the case right now because
even towards the east it's all cleared
up as far as storms go at least for now
101 our official high for the day today
after only 99 yesterday this is still
below average 77 for a start felt real
nice this morning 116 the record on the
state back in 2007 this is our 100
degree guarantee that means silver state
refrigeration hvac will date another 100
to our two local charities of benefit
vets and pets yes
98 degrees right now for spring valley
99 centenny hills 100 even for north las
vegas 103 the east side 102 whitney
ranch green valley included 100 for
henderson and southern highlands you're
currently at 100 degrees as well 96 for
sandy valley 108 in death valley we've
seen it hotter than that that's an
improvement right 101 in
mesquite and 102 currently for you
joining us down the river in laughlin so
when you look to the east you're not
seeing those clouds build up because
these areas here
in kingman and just to the north clear
to finding the storms you've got to go
way off into flagstaff and the grand
canyon that's where the monsoon is at
right now the reason that's being pushed
out towards the east is this big dip
here in the jet stream pushing that off
towards east that southwest flow is also
bringing us those southwest winds that
we're currently seeing outside that
we'll continue to see the world too here
are your neighborhoods when you see
these colors light up that means we get
some wind clearing up tonight and
tomorrow morning and then back again
tomorrow in the afternoon breezy again
expected for tomorrow and that goes for
thursday too when you see those purple
colors with red colors in here that's
strong wind we're not seeing this right
now this is just going to be breezy
winds for these next few days we are
going to increase the heat as we
decrease those winds later in the week
though look at these numbers so below
average today but we start climbing up
to 107 on saturday this is normal on
friday that's our normal temperature but
then next week it starts to get a little
excessive when we start reaching 110
degrees so here's your forecast 78
overnight clear and nice another
comfortable morning there'll be some
evening breezes tomorrow your high 101
degrees breezy and hot however still
below our normal of 104 degrees your
extended forecast your eight on the
eight forecast shows look at that like
we said the numbers go up breezy through
a few more days here those numbers you
see next week though
are nowhere near reaching the record
temperatures so that's the good news
trying to put some good goods now chris
was just mentioning that so far it's
been not too bad this summer it really
hasn't been through june well good
because we're going to be welcoming a
lot of basketball players got an nba
team coming to vegas as a matter of fact
we've got 30 nba teams coming yeah the
nba summer
oh yeah